the fair value of a futures contract is
the price of the contract at which a
buyer of the stock would be neutral
between buying it on in an actual stock
exchange and actually buying the stock
and agreeing to buy the futures contract
or a seller of the stock would be
neutral between selling it right now in
the actual exchange versus agreeing to
go short or agreeing to be on the
selling side for a futures contract and
the fair value tends to be quoted for
the front month or the next expiring
futures contract next expiring futures
contract and to see how this works why
someone would be neutral between say
buying something now for $100 and
agreeing to buy it maybe next month at
102 dollars think of it this way if they
want to just hold that stock a month or
two or three from now they could pay a
hundred dollars right now or they could
put they could take their hundred
dollars so they could either just buy it
right now or they could stick it maybe
in a money market account they could get
some interest for the next few weeks and
then they could buy the futures contract
so if they got interest of two dollars
if they kept that hundred dollars in a
say a money market account for the next
until the actual contract date for that
futures contract they'd be neutral I
could spend a hundred dollars today or I
could put a hundred dollars in a money
market account get two dollars in
interest and I'm not going to worry
about the dividends right now if a
dividend happens then obviously you
would want to pay less for this thing
where you didn't get the dividend but
assuming no dividends you'd say well or
I'd be willing to pay a hundred two
dollars for that if this was only a
hundred one dollars if the price of the
futures contract was 101 dollars then
you'd say wait if the price of the
futures contract is $101 I would rather
I would rather put my money in a money
market account get two dollars of
interest and buy it in a month for 101
dollars I'll essentially get an extra
dollar if I do that if the price if the
price is 100 and if the price is at one
hundred and three dollars did you say
well gee if I want to hold that stock a
month or two from now I'm way better
buying it right now or another way to
think about it if the price is at 100
three dollars and I'm a seller of the
stock instead of selling it today for
$100 I'm better and let's say I really
need $100 right now I'm better off
borrowing $100 right now paying maybe
two dollars in interest and then selling
it a month later for a hundred and three
dollars so the fair value is the price
at which a buyer seller is neutral
between buying and selling the stock or
entering into a futures contract I'll go
into a normal bit more detail in the
next video but its main use as an
indicator of what's likely to happen
once a market opens and that's because
futures markets futures markets trade
much have much longer trading hours
sometimes 24 hours than traditional
stock markets so if you can imagine if a
price is if the price of a futures
contract is trading below its fair value
the only reason why that would happen is
if a lot of people are actually
expecting once the stock once the market
opens that the stock price is going to
go down